she was identified via fingerprints but
her I'm the person who found Marisela
and so you found I found her Wow
she was identified her body was in bad
wasn't it was in a bad state of decomp
they were able to get fingerprints to
match to where her family had filed a
missing-persons report
but her body was so decomposed that they
had to remove her hands and then and
then put them in saline solution so they
could rehydrate them and then to take
that to take the fingerprints there's
one story about Marisela and about her
family and about all the people that
have been deeply impacted by her death
that's just one first Hey yeah of one of
you know human so you amplify that story
3,000 times you know it's a lot of it's
a lot of sorrow especially for the
orange tags and is there's over a
thousand people in Arizona that have
disappeared basically the families one
that we'll never probably find out what
happened to them and you know that's
this horrible aspect to it the desert is
used as a way to deter migrants and it
kills them and then it destroys their
bodies the goal this project I mean it
is it's participatory so these tags on
this wall were filled out by about 500
volunteers at University of Pennsylvania
several months ago and so with every
exhibition that we're doing in a 150
locations on five continents next year
we send in the kits with the basics and
the information and then they have to
mobilize their communities to fill out
the toe tags so for us the most
important aspect of the other of the
whole thing is the filling out of the
tags that kind of moment of solidarity
with with migrant in and then mounting
it on the wall so that for us is that
you know so it's not just coming and
looking at the toe tag but it's but it's
what does it mean to write down
someone's name and the date they were
found
found in is that a way to raise our
awareness and connect us more of that
issue someone's opinion me contradict
yours what is my friend Alan it's all
about your perspective who are we and
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin we are still on
site at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia for our second
partnership with them we are now going
to be talking with for our second
interview dr. Jason Daley on the
progress look at this thanks the
beautiful project is now officially
behind us the undocumented migration
projects hostile terrain 94 and this is
now on tour across the United States and
internationally which is a huge it will
be yes yep yes and I'm so pumped to
break this down with you and to unpack
getting behind some of the
a tag represents actual human and we got
it looking to get into that to star
Jason we've been fascinated with these
questions I'm really excited to hear
your perspective about them are we
really all wine you know I think as an
anthropologist that's the argument that
we've we're always trying to make is
that whatever differences we might see
between people they're all you know
superficial and we all have a common
ancestor we all come from Africa and
it's a it's kind of our job to to really
I think share that information with the
public people understand that yes we are
in fact all one or what you know we're
all the same species and anything these
divisions that we have are culturally
constructed divisions when you get down
to it the root of it you know of course
for work we're all one I love it and
it's been great actually being at the
analogical Association's annual meeting
because we've been talking about it from
a perspective of yeah but human species
is all one but then as we've been
talking about it on the show so
frequently we also look at whatever you
want to call it the Big Bang or source
or God or creation I don't really care
what you want to call it but since that
13.8 billion years ago moment until now
and four and a half billion years ago
all of the species the 100 million
species that have evolved on the planet
up until now those are also all what
because it all goes back to a single
source
yeah I mean it's you know I think part
of the anthropological endeavor is to
help us understand our place in the
world are how we interact with with one
another how we interact with our
environment and understanding that you
know humans don't live in a vacuum even
if people want to pretend that they do
we know that everything that we do is
deeply connected to the nature to the
environment and we're in this current
moment where people really need to
understand that this relationship
between between us and everybody else on
the planet is a very fragile one and if
we don't take care of the planet we
don't take care of ourselves you know
the the end is unfortunately in sight
and this leads us to the next point as
you said everything is so deeply
interconnected with the air that were
breathing in right now is coming from
phytoplankton and trees the bite of food
that you just had brought prior to this
was nourishing you through the power of
the Sun and the soil that these systems
are so deeply intricately connected that
there is no separation no and do you
think that that is the most upstream
issue that we face
I think it's a big one I mean I think
climate change in you know human induced
climate change I think is a is one of
the most crucial issues of our time and
it connects to all these other issues
that people don't necessarily want to
see the connection between so you know
climate change forces people to leave
their homes because they can't they
can't it's not sustainable in certain
places and so we have a global migration
crisis that's happening now that's
partly the result of you know the way in
which we've interacted with the
environment over the last several
hundred years but but but I do think you
can make that argument that that our
relationship to the planet right now is
the is the most crucial issue that we're
that we're dealing with yeah and it
seems as though the more enlightened we
are about the true interconnectedness
and there being no separation the less
climate issues we have the less mental
health crisis issues we have the less
inequality we have the more we try and
build a social fabric that's conducive
to the flourishing of every single one
of the humans that is here so it feels
like that is the most upstream that is
then solving that could then solve so
many of the downstream what's the quote
one of the big questions is well how do
we catalyze those feelings sort of
interconnectedness or enlighten their
unconditional love yeah it's tough I
mean how do you convince people to be
self-aware
you know you hope as an educator that
you can do that you hope that through
research and the dissemination of
knowledge that people can have a better
understanding of their of their place in
the world but I don't know it feels like
right now we're kind of in dark times or
you know this kind of post truth moment
where people don't necessarily want to
hear things that are that are unpleasant
or that fly in the face of maybe what
they what they think they know about the
world so it's tough I mean getting
people to to wake up and see the writing
on the wall is one of our biggest
challenges right now I think and
anthropologists are are struggling to to
show the general public that look we
need to understand what's going on
our relationships with with the
environment with with one another and I
think social scientists and I think
anthropology in general are really well
positioned to to talk about the human
condition but we got to figure out how
to do it better so that people really
can can understand it and and pick up on
it yes this is the huge point that you
make triple a in anthropology in general
is such a multidisciplinary study and we
adore that and we here on the program
are huge synthesis we try and synthesize
science spirituality all these complex
fields into some sort of a story that
inspires people to take action that
inspires awakening yeah so the
anthropologists also have that as one of
their most pressing issues is figuring
out how to tell the stories in New Age
multimedia content style ways that then
get people inspired to actually
understanding the world that were in
yeah no I mean I think we're in a moment
to where anthropologists are starting to
realize that's the traditional ways in
which we try to disseminate knowledge
aren't accessible to a lot of people you
know the the Journal article the
academic manuscript most of the world
has wants nothing to do with those
things and we need to be more savvy we
need to be
better at translating our work for a
general public and whether that's
through film through social media
through arts I think all of those things
should be should be explored with within
a discipline and it does feel like right
now we're in a moment where people are
starting to really recognize the
importance of that kind that type of
work and I know for me I got a personal
level I've seen the power that comes
with with making your work accessible
and translating inferred for different
kinds of audiences and you know I'm
firmly committed to you know to
exploring those those issues and really
trying to be an example for others in
the discipline that you know the
Anthropology doesn't have to look one
kind of way you can do a whole bunch of
different things I mean that this
exhibition is a case in point okay we'll
reach more people with this exhibition
that I'll ever reach with with a book or
with a journal article yeah and being
able to come further compress yes this
exhibition going on around the world
extremely awakening and also taking
things like even this exhibition and
further compressing it into a short
video above you
yeah powerfully speaking about the
reason why this even exists and putting
that across tik-tok and snapchat right
there you're going really crazy on
getting to Gen Z yeah yeah not awaken
them so I mean the mediums it's so
important the medium becomes the message
yeah is it then that this complexity
that we're talking about of the
current state of our reality and the
trajectory of where we're going and how
we awaken is that the reason why this
was even made in the first place for us
to rise to these challenges what do you
mean by in the first place like a
reality in general or yeah was this
reality made so that we could experience
this adventure in consciousness where we
have this complex reality that we have
to deal with to try in progress you know
that's a good question I think as a as a
not very spiritual person I'm probably
not not the best person to kind of ask
that question to I but I do think you
know we as a species are you know we're
constantly responding to our environment
and our environments change I mean
evolution is a is happening in real time
and so it's it's it's really fascinating
to kind of look and you know how our
species responding to two changes to
history and I think you know at least in
the in the kind of human sense are our
awareness of the world
as really as changes evolved over time
and I think that we're a lot smarter
than we used to be in some ways and then
maybe dumber and others yeah but I do
think these kind of existential
questions are really important than ones
that that everybody's kind of wrapped
you know grappling with you know what is
them what is the meaning of all this
yes where are we headed yes you know his
life about suffering is it about
overcoming suffering or or is it about
is it about something something else
every child be equipped with that
question and probing into their reality
with that such a fundamental for sure
beginning point
okay and now we have this more than ever
we have what we think are two really
interesting ways to look at dichotomy in
a sense you have indigeneity which has
deep interconnectedness to each other to
make sure you have modernity which has
incredible advances in technology but
some lack in interconnectedness and lack
in nature into each other is is a good
idea a marriage sure no I mean I think
just any kind of sensitivity to to the
many issues at play whether that whether
you want to call it you know traditional
knowledge or something else I think the
technology has gotten so far away from
us and we've lost sight of I think some
really crucial kind of elements of what
it means to be human and so I don't
think I don't think you can have these
advances in technology without really
addressing these other kinds of issues I
mean when we do do that we know that it
you know it's not gonna end well for us
so I think that and I think we're in a
moment to where where people are
recognizing that as we see the
technology now happening at a speed that
it's almost incomprehensible we're all
struggling to kind of catch up and I do
feel like there's hope in people
thinking about you know how do we best
equip ourselves for dealing with the
future and for dealing with you know
this runaway technology how do we how do
we pull it back or make sure that it's
developing in a sensitive you know
ethical kind of way yeah it's a if we
continue making technology without being
morally ethically spiritually
philosophically literate in advanced
we're going to
cause greater suffering than if we would
just do those first principles eraqus's
sure sure yeah new technologies like you
said it's incomprehensible there being
there being emerging technologies and
markets are being created meanwhile the
fruits are going to the top 1% 50% of
the new wealth is going at 1% this is
this is ripping apart our social fabric
half of the planets still on 2 dollars
and 50 cents a day or less which is what
we pay here for a cup of coffee these
are very important things to structure
the new architectures that make it so
the democratization of the fruits go out
to us all and think about all the gifts
that get unleashed a median age of
Africa's 18 right now all of the unique
hearts and gifts that get to express
themselves if we can stitch together
that proper social fabric for sure yeah
yeah no it's a I mean technology is
another huge issue that we have to deal
with and I think anthropology has been
very good at making predictions and
trying to make us aware of what you know
the repercussions of what we're doing
and I think I know and you know thinking
into the future in terms of you know
what we do today how's it going to look
in 50 years but then also trying to use
things like archeology to teach us these
important history lessons to remind us
like these things have gone have gone
bad in the past and so we need to pay
attention to you know to our own
histories so that we don't make these
same mistakes again this is a perfect
segue I believe last year around the
same time when we did our first
interview you really expanded my
consciousness to a new dimension of
awareness you taught me that
contemporary archeology can be something
like studying the us-mexico border and
these border crossings that have been
happening and these humans for
a myriad of different reasons are
pursuing in in many ways leaving
something that is less around their
flourishing and trying to get to
something that's more so were they're
flourishing and it's it's so incredible
that that this can even be done around
the around the world where there is a
new chapter in what archaeology can be
when it's done and there's this is
happening all around the world we were
talking about all these different border
conflicts last time as well that are
happening around the world and how we
can try and if it's safe sure if it's
safe then we can go and try and be
contemporary archaeologists to create
things like this so that it doesn't just
get swept under the rug in history
there's everything blown away because if
you you know if you begin trying to
process this this is 3200 over 20 years
something like that or so yeah Wow of
going in and doing fieldwork where I
mean you have to imagine this because
some of these tags we're gonna read them
they say things like the body still has
flesh where the body does not have flesh
so you literally saw this no humans that
burn in those positions sure and and you
have to have the ability to log that and
to understand have enough humanity to
like try and this is such a emotionally
stressing process as well yeah
ah yeah it's a heavy it's a heavy thing
but you know it's trying to remind
people or raise awareness many people
don't know this thing is going on and so
I think part of my job as an
anthropologist is to disseminate
knowledge about the world people can
understand hey we've been having a
humanitarian crisis at the us-mexico
border for a long time and it's taken
thousands of people's lives and it
continues to do so right you know right
now yeah so how do we raise raise that
awareness it's again it's just so nuts
thinking about you and other members of
your team going into the field and going
through this like you said heavy process
of identifying things like humans across
20 years who've you found 3200 but
there's oh but not me not me though you
so tell you this but this this info this
info comes from the Pima County office
of the medical examiner and so and we've
we have found human remains but but many
most of these are you know found by
other hikers law enforcement Wow
you know hunters that has to my grits
who call the police and say you know
someone disappeared and so it's a wide
range of circumstances in which these
bodies were found hikers law officers
Pima theshia Pima County meconium in
what state in Arizona in Arizona
Pima County Arizona a majority of this
is the Arizona so this is our this is
Arizona in Mexico yeah only Arizona
Mexico this year the other so if you
were to expand this into California or
to Texas New Mexico you know you would
add a lot more a lot more bodies that's
one of the four states def is on border
okay so one out of four states has 3200
so far identified show tags recovered so
the orange are unidentified bodies and
the manila represent people who have
names so there's about 1200 unidentified
bodies that have just been buried in a
pauper's grave Wow
okay there's 1200 orange tags yeah and
those are unidentified yep Wow
okay let's do this let's let's take one
all right I'll remember where it's
coming from it's why it's gonna come
down in a minute
so so this is an unidentified tag and
this is again this is so this is a human
that was discovered but unidentifiable
yep yep and it could be because they
they themselves that the body condition
yeah one of the items on the tags is
decomposed yeah so then you can't
actually identify facial features so if
it's like skeletal remains you know
there's no way to do fingerprints you
can do a DNA sample but it doesn't
necessarily you can take a DNA sample
but if you don't have a comparative
sample you know to match it to then it's
not gonna it's not gonna do you any good
so you can extract DNA from from
skeletal remains do a DNA analysis but
if someone hasn't submitted that
person's DNA or a relative you're not
gonna you're not gonna have anything to
match it to so and people don't know
that the relatives are that they're dead
they don't know whether or if they if
they've disappeared
they may not know where they disappeared
maybe they disappeared in Mexico or in
California you know people just don't
know
oh my goodness okay so Wow so there's
this breakdown of unidentified and
identified and seeing a decomposed body
and not being able to know even who the
true human is what who what their what
their name was what their family was
what their unique gift that they were
could have brought to the world is
ambitions we're friends were yeah so
that is that is unidentified now we will
go with identified well here how about
this one yeah okay so this isn't
identified and there's then there's
about 2000 identified yeah okay okay and
so we're looking at a female that was
around the age of 30 yep her name was
Carmen Marisela hogweed pelea Carmita
Marisela Zog Weepu yeah yeah and now how
did you even gain the name that they
have identification she was identified
via fingerprints but her I'm the person
who found Marisela and so you found I
found her Wow
she was identified her body was in bad
wasn't it was in a bad state of decomp
they were able to get fingerprints to
match to where her family had filed a
missing-persons report
but her body was so decomposed that they
had to remove her hands and then and
then put them in saline solution so they
could rehydrate them then to take them
to take the fingerprints oh my gosh
Wow okay
she was from Ecuador she was a mother of
three and and you learned that
information is well when you with the
family I went to Ecuador I went to
Ecuador to meet with her family I've met
with New York she's kind of a big
inspiration for this project there's
been a lot of time writing about her
family and about the impact that her
death had on her on her kids oh my
goodness so you went to Ecuador met with
her family also New York yeah so what
was the reason why she had left you know
her family was was poor they were living
in a like one-room dirt Shack with a
dirt floor and you know she said to her
family you know my kids are starving
here and so I've got to go and try to
find some way to support them I mean one
of the last things she said to them was
you know my kids are dying of hunger
here and so I cannot just sit idly by as
it happened so I'm gonna I'm gonna
migrate and whatever my fate is at least
I've tried you know I've tried to
improve that improve their lives
Wow Wow
and this is this is a how many how many
children again three three three kids
trying to provide them with a better
life yeah Marisela
Wow Ecuadorian yep
and just even to identify her the hands
needed to go in saline solution to get a
fingerprint and firm it she'd only been
dead maybe three or four days when we
found her then she laid in she was in
cold storage uninvolved for like three
weeks and so by the time the body was
returned I mean she was in it was a
really bad condition and one things that
her family mean her family was told not
to open the coffin is the body's not
it's not in a good shape you don't you
really shouldn't see that and but of
course everybody wanted to see you see
her the kids wanted to say goodbye yeah
so they opened the coffin and it was
incredibly traumatizing for the family
we do in that situation this yeah this
is all Wow I mean the body itself yeah I
mean wow
so the but yeah the body itself has a
storage processed so that it doesn't
further decomposed there's the family
that wants to see the body that can get
traumatized triggered by seeing it but
wants to say goodbye the best solution
is to not have this happening yeah yes
and the cause of cause of death Issy OD
and probable hypothermia him yeah she
probably died from a combination of
hyperthermia and a pre-existing kidney
conditioner that she was left behind by
her group and died by herself and
probably because she's couldn't she
couldn't walk anymore because of her but
because of the heat and because of a
this medical problem that she was having
this is such a heavy
so heavy oh this is it is this
ridiculously heavy and what we what do
we do we have people that want to feed
their children that want to gain greater
economic opportunity to do so what is
the way to make it so that this problem
is not continuing you know I think we
got to work on comprehensive immigration
reform you know people need to migrate
we want the labor so we should make we
should make their ability to move
between countries safer but also I think
we need to invest in these places any
people don't want to migrate I mean they
would prefer to stay home and the way
global inequality works is that there
are many countries that are you know
being abused by by powerful nations and
we like keeping them underdeveloped they
provide us with a cheap source of labor
we're able to exploit them in all kinds
of ways and so I think it's not just
immigration reform and allowing this
this kind of free movement of people but
also investing in infrastructure in
these places so that people don't have
to move I think that's I think you can't
have one without the other
so following a power-law distribution
where there's only a couple economic
powers that have vast majority of the
global wealth they get to bully around
other countries in the world and not
necessarily focus on uplifting the other
countries in the world but just
restating rules and regulations for
their own favor in the absolute the
worst case scenario that that's what
that's what happens and so it's both a
process of actually truly finding the
best means for investing into those
regions to enable people to not need to
make these migrations but also create
reform migration to make it so that
people that are seeking to migrate can
do so without the possibility of dot
data in their process those are the two
yeah yeah
I still can't believe that this is only
one of four states so you think that the
number could be in ten top ten thousand
yeah overly made Texas there's thousands
of people who died in Texas and we know
very little about what's going on there
Arizona I mean New Mexico is
increasingly becoming a new crossing
quarter people are dying there now you
know and I think about with this stuff
like here's one story about mati Sela
and about her family and about all the
people that have been deeply impacted by
her death that's just one of her snakes
yeah of one human you know human so you
amplify that story 3,000 times you know
it's a lot of it's a lot of sorrow
especially for the orange tags I mean
there's there's over a thousand people
in Arizona that have disappeared
basically the families one that we'll
never probably find out what happened to
them and you know that's this horrible
aspect to it the desert is used as a way
to deter migrants and it kills them and
then it destroys their bodies and I
think you know people will say well you
know at least like with my t-cell oh we
have we got her body back we were able
to bury her we know where she is now but
you know I work with families that
they've had family members disappear and
they both never know you know her
15 year old cousin disappeared a year
after she died and we still haven't
found him and he's it could be on this
wall is one of the unidentified tags or
he could just have disappeared in the
desert be eaten by vultures completely
destroyed and and we'll never full never
find any of his remains
the process of amplifying the sorrow of
one human passing in this circumstance
to 3200 of them that have been the ones
that have been identified 2,000
identified 200 not just only that you're
aware of you know on just one fourth of
the order this is quite a heavy feeling
so there's
there's more family members there's more
ambitions that are unfulfilled family
members that gain trauma there's ones
I've never been never identified and
viewing it that way
tells us a story that do we really want
to inflict that much more suffering you
know do we want to know what could have
been unleashed from their ambitions yeah
it's a I mean it keeps happening it's
happening right now
you know this has been over 20 years and
it doesn't seem like it's gonna stop
anytime soon unfortunately so this is
experiential immersive art that is also
contemporary archaeology and believe we
talked about this a little bit last time
but this style of portraying the
information has a profound impact for
those that are willing to slow down and
look at the tags tisha and aim to really
immerse themselves in a human's reasons
for going across them well the goal this
project I mean it is it's participatory
so these tags on this wall were filled
out by about 500 volunteers at the
University of Pennsylvania several
months ago and so with every exhibition
that we're doing in a hundred and 50
locations on five continents next year
we send in the kits with the basics and
the information and then they have to
mobilize their communities to fill out
the toe tags so for us the most
important aspect of the whole thing is
the filling out of the tags that kind of
moment of solidarity with with migrants
and then mounting it on the wall
so that's process you know so it's not
just coming and looking at the toe tag
but it's but it's what does it mean to
write down someone's name and the date
they were found in the condition
found in is that a way to raise our
awareness and connect us more of that
issue
the answer is absolutely Wow
so um a hundred and fifty locations
across five continents yeah we're hoping
the rich one we're hoping to break Asia
we haven't gotten to Asia yet but we're
in every we're on five continents right
now
you heard that let's get into Asia
that's huge yeah so we want to get this
into Asia we want to help be able to
fund you have a funding team now yep
yeah and this is great actually to see
your team here helping you get the right
resources together to make you have to
make these kids
yeah and the kids like you said are
extremely special because they have the
2,000 identified tags and the 1200
unidentified tags but they're blamed yep
and then the community has to assemble a
team that then goes through the process
of writing these yeah and then that
immerses you in the experience of
creating a tag to represent a human yeah
that's that plus the immersive
experience well side of it are really
great components to increase the
awareness yeah I mean we hope that you
know by writing out these names of the
dead it's in some way bringing them kind
of back to life you know breathing life
into this into these toe tags yeah just
for a brief moment and so to remind
folks that you know they're not
forgotten even if they're unidentified
we're still at least recognizing that
that is a person and you know that's a
that's real crucial for us to just and
connect it with as many communities as
possible so we're all over the United
States Latin America Europe Australia
and Africa and we're trying to connect
with different communities that have
been impacted with by migration so we
have a heavy presence in Mexico in
Central America but also in the
Mediterranean so we'll bring we'll bring
this to places like Lampa deucey bring
this to Morocco will bring us to Athens
and work with communities area
especially refugee and migrant
communities to help us build these these
exhibitions and to show some solidarity
so we're doing we do a lot of outreach
with different communities and then
trying to connect the she's trying to
show that the us-mexico border is not
happening in isolation right we're
having a global migration crisis and
this is just one of many crises that are
happening right now and can we can we
bring awareness there but then also
increase our awareness about what's
going on in these other places as well
at the same time
a global migration crisis that's
happening with an unnecessary amount of
suffering and death and that by getting
other people to more deeply immerse
themselves in the emotions of the crises
across the planet then it increases our
awareness around it and desire to make
solutions as soon as possible Jason this
is ridiculously heavy but it's also the
exact amount of awakening that needs to
happen this is the style of severe kind
of like Yankee style awakenings you're
sure that yeah does that's kind of ringg
them yeah I mean it's it's it's not
subtle yeah you know and I think we
don't live in a moment where subtlety is
working and so this is like look at it
recognize that there's a crisis going on
and then ask yourself what am I gonna do
about this you know how am I gonna make
this better
doing care and so when someone next to
me hears someone say something bad about
a migrant or about the us-mexico border
what's the image that you're gonna have
in your mind is it going to be you know
this anti-immigrant kind of headline in
a newspaper or is it going to be this
yes you know that's that's that's the
hope
because when you are in that situation
and you're able to pull this out and
properly explain this it actually has
the potential to change the other
person's worldview for the better yeah I
hope yeah and this is also a great idea
for other areas of conflict on borders -
around the world if if those that are
watching have order conflicts happening
they themselves can make similar
exhibitions and it's designed to be you
know relatively affordable so it's only
it's $1,500 for the whole kit okay yeah
and so and if people can't afford to do
it will subsidize it so you know where
the word is trying to make this as
accessible as possible like all of our
Latin American shows are subsidized all
of our Africa shows are subsidized but
it's just if someone is interested in
what wants to bring us to their
community wants to connect it with
issues that are relevant to their
community in terms of immigration border
security you know we're more than happy
to partner with them so people should
get in touch I mean you can go to our we
have our website hostile 2094 org they
can get tons of information there they
can drop us an email if they're
interested in learning about becoming a
host or and getting getting involved in
this and in different places so I mean
we've got you know we're at a hundred
and thirty confirmed locations right now
we anticipate that we'll hit 150 by the
end of the year so people can look at
the map and go you know where my
community it is happening is because it
is it nearby
and for a lot of people it really it
will be so that's the goal we're gonna
push this out starting in May and it
will run all the way until until
November 2nd
from May till November 2nd of 2028 20
yeah so it sort of staggers it's like we
have open live show opens
it shows opening in May and then we have
some summer stuff and then late fall is
or early fall it's a lot of Europe and
then all of the u.s. shows launch in
Latin America happens kind of in the
summer and then all of the European
shows and then and then the u.s. stuff
happens between late August and late
October and then the final version of
this will be at the Corcoran Museum in
Washington DC where we'll build this
wall but we'll use tags that have been
filled up with people from 150 locations
around the globe and so you'll be able
to go and see this and see this thing
that's been built by literally thousands
of people yeah and we estimate that that
we could have 60,000 people filling our
toe tags as part of the hundred and
fifty shows yeah yeah so you know it's
it's it's it's gaining steam it's been
really hum yes and really humbling to
see all the support that we've got yes
that's a massive awakening for the
60,000 people that will be filling these
out plus about hopefully hundred
thousand plus people that will be
viewing it and the data is there which
is another very interesting thing that
that we need to be archaeologists be
contemporary archaeologists about is
finding the data for California New
Mexico Texas making similar displays
across other border conflicts around the
world can we identify the humans and the
reasons why and the trauma that's been
inflicted on their families and can we
build a social fabric that does not have
that happening anymore we can the answer
is yes but galvanizing the awareness to
do so requires movements like this I
need ask this question how do you
yourself stay emotionally resilient
given the stories that you were just
explaining to us you know I think I have
a good team I work with a lot of
students and other collaborators who
were all really supportive of one
another
we do a lot of talk therapy we sort of
work these issues out I mean this is not
easy for us and and I was telling
someone earlier today every time I fell
at a toe tag
you know I respond in a different way
and sometimes it's in a really kind of
heavy way like you know it I can just
find myself breaking down in the middle
of it and just be totally surprised by
that reaction like I would think that
after so much time around they said I
would be sensitized but it's actually
the complete the complete opposite so
we're just we just try to take care of
ourselves you know do a lot of self-care
and then also remind ourselves to that
that I'm very privileged to be able to
raise awareness about this issue and so
as horrible it is for me to be involved
in the stuff and to see this trauma over
and over again it's not as bad as what's
happened to these folks and so that kind
of keeps me grounded
in terms of recognizing my privilege in
this space and then but also really
inspiring me to say if I don't do this
then who is and so I you know the the
the lives that we're trying to raise
awareness about I think really energize
all of us as a team
Imus issued this saying something
similar where I previously hadn't made a
really strong emotional
understanding that this tank is
representing a human of such complex
existence and that's the style of
response that we yep we want and this is
something that we deeply immerse our
emotions into and perspective behind and
galvanized solutions to and
again I'm just really grateful that you
and your team have been going with this
much steam moving forward well thank you
well we're so off we're gonna keep it
going yet we've got 11 months to go till
this thing is done so yeah I actually
feel like this has this is the exact
thing that shakes towards the solution
chic so awareness towards the solutions
and then can hopefully shed light on all
the other border conflicts and forced
migrations and and can hopefully make
more Wow
thank you for all of this thank you for
all this breakdown and and our hearts
are with the families and these
spirits that are no longer here and that
are sacrificed for the for us to build
the next world that does not have these
issues yeah well thank you thanks Jason
thanks for coming oh no my girls no
thank you it was always a always a
pleasure you are just you guys are doing
incredible work thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts and the
comments blow on the episode let us know
what you're thinking please support
hostile terrain 94 org support the
undocumented migration project please
support them the links are in the bye
below you can follow Jason as well
across his platforms all those links are
below you can learn more about the
project you can get involved you can
donate to support them to support the
exhibitions that we're doing in
underserved communities we have an
online shop where you can buy you can
Christmas shop you know that there's
lots of things that we have that we're
using to to help support this project so
we've got a pretty heavy online presence
there's all of those different ways to
get involved please reach out and get
involved please everyone and support the
American Anthropological Association as
well
it's really important to remember that
we had only went through one of these
examples and that if you amplify that
example then that many times that gives
you a deeper resonance with what this
actually is and you can support us too
so we can continue doing great things
like coming on site to incredible
conferences like Triple A to interview
great leaders like Jason please help
support us you can find our links in the
bye below and go and build that future
architect the social fabrics for more
flourishing around the world everyone
thank you very much for tuning in see
you soon thank you
thank you
we'll hopefully see you in San Francisco
we're working on that this is insane
absolutely the fact that we are doing
this - yeah had to happen
it has it had it had it had to happen to
awaken us we won't awaken any fizzes
[Music]